Messerstecherei im Flüchtlingsheim in
Berlin-Marzahn ist es am Abend zu einem
Streit gekommen dann wurde zugestochen
der Verletzte wurde vor Ort notärztlich
versorgt haben ins Krankenhaus ein
Tatverdächtiger konnte nach ersten
Informationen auf einem Spielplatz
festgenommen werden wir gehen direkt
dorthin wenn meine Kollegin Annika rasch
ist an der Unterkunft mit weiteren
Details schön guten Morgen Annika was
hat sich da genau abgestimmt
ja Patricia gestern Abend um 18 Uhr gab
es hier eine Auseinandersetzung in der
Flüchtlingsunterkunft bei dem eben eine
Person durch eine Stichverletzung schwer
verletzt wurde die Person ist jetzt im
Krankenhaus und der Täter konnte nicht
weit von hier auf einem Spielplatz
festgenommen werden gibt es schon
irgendwelche Informationen über das
Opfer und den mutmaßlichen Täter
genau bei dem Opfer soll es sich um
einen 25-jährigen Mann handeln der eben
in dieser Unterkunft hier hinter mir
lebt über den Täter ist bisher nichts
bekannt auch nicht ob diese Person dann
auch in dieser Unterkunft gelebt hat wie
die beiden in was für einem Verhältnis
die beiden standen wir wissen aber dass
dieses Opfer eben gestern ins
Krankenhaus gebracht wurde und in einer
Notoperation dann operiert wurde aber
eben auch schwer verletzt wurde und
jetzt noch im Krankenhaus ist
kannst du uns sagen was genau ist es für
eine Unterkunft wer lebt dort
die Unterkunft wurde 2015 eröffnet das
ist ein ehemaliges Bürogebäude dass man
dann eben 2015 und 2016 umgebaut hat zu
ihm einer Unterkunft für geflüchtete die
eben jetzt Platz hat in zwei
verschiedenen Gebäuden für 550 Personen
unterschiedlicher Herkunft das sind
teilweise Familien aber eben auch
alleinreisende Männer und da muss man
eben auch dazu sagen dass es eben bei so
vielen Kulturen die zusammenkommen in
solchen Unterkünften das sind oft bis zu
zehn verschiedene Kulturen das ist eben
da dann auch zu diesem aufeinanderprall
von verschiedenen Kulturen kommt aber
eben mehr zu diesen Hintergrund und zu
dem Verhältnis von Opfer und Täter
gestern Abend können wir eben noch nicht
sagen Annika mit allen Details zu einer
Messerstecherei in einer
Flüchtlingsunterkunft hier in Berlin
Annika vielen herzlichen dank dir
[Musik]